découverte pour ces élèves de première
de leur nouvel outil de travail
le lycée dumont-d'urville à maurepas
fait partie des 3 130 établissements
franciliens a opté cette année pour le
numérique
la tablette au lycée c'est beaucoup plus
que des manuels scolaires c'est
évidemment 9 manuels scolaires en
seconde cette manuel en première mais
c'est aussi un espace numérique de
travail à laboratoire de langues
intégrer un site pour découvrir des
stages ainsi d'orientation un site aussi
pour avoir d'autres ressources
pédagogiques vidéo audio
ces tablettes sont confiés gratuitement
aux élèves durant leur scolarité dans le
secondaire
objectif que chacun soit sur un même
pied d'égalité en matière de numérique
je trouve ça génial le principe d'avoir
une tablette de remplacer toutes celles
où toute cette lourdeur qu'on pouvait
avoir dans le sac et ça pourra nous
permettre de plus avancées au niveau du
système scolaire
ce dispositif représente pour la région
un investissement de 150 millions
d'euros sur trois ans particularité le
moteur de recherche ainsi que la
tablette sont 100% français j'avais le
choix entre un fabricant américain bien
connu avec une pomme est une société
française une start up française
s'assume
j'ai choisi la tablette française parce
que si la région capitale ne choisit pas
la technologie française qui le fera au
total en ile-de-france 160000 tablettes
vont être distribués dans les lycées
ayant opté pour le numérique